chaque année washington et ses monuments
attire plus de 20 millions de visiteurs
derrière la blancheur de certains de ses
murs se cache parfois une histoire plus
sombre
[Musique]
la maison blanche a entre autres été
construite par des esclaves qui ont
travaillé à la carrière de pierre mais
aussi sur le chantier selon
l'association historique de la maison
blanche
ils ont également contribué à la rebâtir
après sa destruction pendant la guerre
anglo american de 1812 il faut dire que
plusieurs des premiers présidents
américains étaient eux-mêmes
propriétaires d'esclaves
c'est le cap george washington qui n'a
jamais habité à la maison blanche
n'était pas terminée mais sous sept de
ses successeurs
thomas jefferson à zachary taylor en
passant par un goût jackson des esclaves
ont travaillé à la résidence officielle
fixée
fox à l'autre bout de l'avenue
pennsylvania on trouve un autre bâtiment
emblématique de washington esclavage a
aussi joué un rôle important dans la
construction du capitole symbole de la
démocratie américaine
les preuves historiques montrent même
que la statue au sommet du dôme
la statue de la liberté a ironiquement
pu être érigée grâce aux efforts et les
prix d' un homme qui lui n'était pas
libre le gouvernement américain n'a
jamais lui-même détenu d'esclaves
mais il a payé des propriétaires d'état
comme le merlin ou la virginie pour
utiliser leurs esclaves comme main
d'oeuvre
la situation géographique de la ville de
washington entre le nord et le sud
on a fait un endroit stratégique dans le
commerce d'esclaves
on le souligne par exemple dans le film
en esclavage cette production a été
inspiré du récit de solomon northrup un
afro-américain du nord qui a été attiré
vers la capitale où on l'a emprisonné
avant de le vendre dans le sud
washington c'est aussi le monument de
linken et l'émancipation des esclaves
la ville a été un refuge pour de
nombreuses à pratiquer pendant la guerre
de sécession
un siècle plus tard c'est également ici
que martin luther king a prononcé son
fameux discours l'un des plus importants
dans la lutte pour les droits civiques
le rôle la capitale a donc évolué au
rythme des changements sociaux aux états
unis